hello we are delighted you joined us for
today's webinar
NGS live in your lab in 30 days I in
Cristina mahalik of lovers and I'll be
moderating this session today's
education web seminar is presented by
elaborate believing scientific social
networking website and provider a
virtual events and webinars today's
webinar is sponsored by kyochon hi Jen
another one holding company is the
leading global provider of sample essays
technologies that are used to transform
biological materials into valuable
molecular information sample
technologies are used to isolate and
process DNA RNA and proteins from
biological samples such as blood or
tissue assay technologies are then used
to missus isolated biomolecules visible
and ready for interpretation kyochon
markets more than 500 products around
the world selling those consumable kits
in automation systems to customers
through for customer classes molecular
diagnostics human healthcare apply
testing forensics veterinary testing and
food safety pharma pharmaceutical and
biotechnology companies in academia life
science research let's get started you
can post questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so this is Tyson in the
Q&A box which will open we click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of this slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
feeling
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window for report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
this is an educational webinar in this
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CC button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speakers
mekong PhD in Saline ethically he is
currently a product director at hydrogen
responsible for content and application
development of cancer molecular research
and diagnostics she led efforts to
develop and commercialize the June
reader NGS system she has years of
experience working in the diagnostic and
pharmaceutical industries in various
development product management marketing
and strategic planning roles she started
her career as a biomedical student
having published many peer-reviewed
articles in a diagnostic patent it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Kong dr. Kong
before is yours thank you Christina for
a gentle generous introduction thank you
everyone for taking time out of your day
to attend our webinar here today my
colleagues Escala Mexicali and myself
like to present you the gene reader NGS
with them and tell you a little bit
about how your lab can go live with NGS
in 30 days we have structured today's
presentations as follows
I will begin by telling you a little bit
more around the concept with live in 30
days and my colleague solemn will
introduce some more information on the
gene reader NGS wisdom the surgery plate
for NGS live in 30 days I would like to
present to you from the challenges to
implementing NGS workflow and explain
how the gene reader system is different
I would also like to share some the data
we have generated internally at occasion
as well as externally in collaboration
with some customers so as many of you
already know
NGS has proven to be a very powerful
tool in understanding the complex
genetics behind a tumor or cancer but
there are also many barriers to a
broader adoption of this fantastic
technology owing to a number of factors
for example the current solutions on the
market are fragmented and the workflow
needs custom assembly of various
components from various vendors
second while sequencing is relatively
easy the challenge of analyzing and
interpreting the data can sometimes be
very daunting to a laboratory especially
one that does not have a lot of by
dramatic experience and last but not
least the cost of the NGS run can be
quite high and obscure to a laboratory
and this is exactly why we developed the
gene reader system by offering an
integrated workflow and by also offering
and seamlessly integrated by dramatic
solutions as part of the solutions and
last but not least offering a to
transplant cost structure to ensure its
cost effectiveness typically in the
laboratory the process to bring up an
NGS workflow takes around six to nine
months this is because a laboratory
begins by choosing a sequencing platform
first and then the lab has to choose an
upstream sample preparation platform
and then has to find a QC solution to
the workflow as well as a bang dramatic
solution to it and then the laboratory
needs to design and perform its own
verifications assay to ensure that all
components work together and if if they
don't the lab has to conduct
troubleshooting and optimization
processes and this process goes on until
the laboratory obtain a satisfactory
result and can then go live with an NGS
test and this is typically a six to
nine-month process but for the gene
reader system once we install the system
because it comes with all the components
that are needed the laboratory is ready
to perform a verification process with
the protocol and expected results that
also provided as part of the system the
laboratory can then go live with NGS in
as few as 30 days and this is because
the NGS process is inherently complex
and spends multiple days it goes from
nucleic acid extractions to target
enrichment
survivor preparation to sequencing
itself and then to data analysis and
interpretation and the NGS the gene
readers NGS system comes with all the
automation platforms or the hardware
software as well as reagents to cover
each and every step of this complex
process in addition we also offer
several QC platforms that can be used in
this process to make sure that every
step of the way is performed up to this
expectation moreover every team reader
system comes with a iPad an iPad and an
app called gene read assistant this is
an app that takes the place of a
traditional handbook and provides a
interactive and simplistic user
interface to allow the laboratory to
follow the protocol and and control the
operation of the workflow while
Spinelli's the teen reader also comes
with a jingling link software to
specifically allow bi-directional
communication between the NGS workflow
and the laboratory information
management system that's allowing a
laboratory full visibility full control
and chain-of-custody so the entire NGS
process and this system is available in
the United States with a brand new
chemistry and what do we mean by full
protocol for control and what does a
laboratory need to do in order to test
and go liable the NGS when with the NGS
operation so as as you saw before that
multiple steps are in this whole process
to get to an interpretation or
interpretive report and what we've done
on the bottom of the slide is by
combining this entire system with a
rigorous testing of a set of horizon
reference standards to provide a fully
integrated solution where the phone
process control and very robust set of
performance data that the laboratory can
use to measure and measuring against and
to guide their setup of the workflow
just to give you an example of the
results that you can expect this is a
set of data obtained from FTE reference
standards some horizons you can see the
gene list of genes and variants on the
left hand side with the expected leo
frequencies in the middle of the graph
with a lower and higher range you can
see highlighted in red the
the efficiencies have obtained I'm a
gene reader system very closely aligned
blizzard ranges with a very tight a
standard deviation next to it and this
is obtained on the average of ten press
coverage and as you can see we have
pretty uniformly high coverage across
the board this is perhaps better
represented in a graphical manner as
shown here where each gene and variants
is listed on the bottom in the x-axis
and the variant frequency is listed on
the y-axis and each single dot
represents a separate experiment in
which we vary the number of different
parameters either the site at which the
experiment is conducted there operator
the sample batch or reagent batch and
the level of flexing that we apply to
that particular experiment and again as
you can see regardless of the variables
you obtain a very robust and consistent
level of performance across the board
this is just to give you a reference
that Palmetto gbas recommendation in NGS
operation recommends of reproducibility
study covering exactly other parameters
that we just went through each of them
operator in terms of lumps and batches
in terms of sites and the region loss so
this is this is the process that
laboratories typically go through and
this is exactly process that we at
Teijin have carried out so one of our
collaborators and customers after
Yasmina Terry at Legacy Health levels in
Oregon has used has been using the gene
readers as 2016
and in her experience this kind of data
provides a very robust and and
good reference standard prefer to set up
an NGS operation and this data said is
the first of its kind at the very end of
this hour you will also be able to watch
a very brief video interview of dr.
Akari in which she will share her
experience using the system as well this
slide is a set of results tested from
liquid biopsy samples and a lower allele
frequency of 1 percent again you see the
list of genes and variants on the
left-hand side for the expected allele
frequencies in the middle and the
standard deviation or the lower and
upper bounds around it again highlighted
in red you see the observed of the O
frequencies on the gene reader to be
very closely aligned with the reference
standards and the gang will have a
uniformly high coverage of half of the
genes and variants and this is again
meeting or exceeding the recommendation
of circulating tumor DNA testing as
published by palmetto GBA next I would
like to show you a two pieces of studies
that we are publishing the process of
publishing with in collaboration with
some other sites this is what is what
the Dartmouth University and we
conducted a concordance study between
the gene Reader and the numbers and via
two paths one and again as you can see
each dot represents a single single
variant with the allele frequencies
plotted out based on G readers output as
well as the alternative NGS platform
output and again as you can see from
very low to very high allele frequency
range there's a very close correlation
between the two platform and this is
replicated with another study conducted
with University
along on another alternative NGS pathway
we also have a number of puffs of
abstract published at various
conferences and trade shows to highlight
one of them which is and global which is
taking place in Berlin in April this
year we have seven abstract septa there
so if any of you will be joining us in
Berlin I welcome you to come posters as
well as our workshop and and booth I
would like to end my part of the
presentations I also sharing some
experience from Professor Tom Lupo ads
University of Graz in Austria ESL will
be one of our early adopters of the gene
reader system and he sees a lot of value
in a laboratory in one vendor providing
a total solution for the entire NGS
workflow for laboratory to enable a much
faster testing process and a laboratory
to live in as few as 30 days so I would
like to end here and share a very brief
video from dr. tom brokaw sharing his
experience and then I will pass the
floor to my colleague Solomon so Polly
thank you my research were mainly
focused on bringing new technologies
into medicine
you cannot sufficiently predict the
behavior of a disease so we need deeper
insight into the molecular biology
underlying a disease and that's where
sequencing and more
protesting comes into play we had to
learn that the single I traded parameter
is not able to describe an individual
disease because it's influenced by so
many different parameters and now thanks
to an extraction sequencing we are able
to get a much more comprehensive view on
the variety of mechanisms underlying
disease we learned about the importance
of an complete integrated workflow if
you compile your analytical process like
different products and technologies from
different companies you never know how
they fit together
and to have reliable results at the end
you have to validate the whole workflow
and therefore we are so in favor of the
approach of cryogen do it is already on
an industrial scale so the workload is
not on the users level major
underestimation is that at the moment
people just calculate the costs of an
analysis not considering the cost of
validation of a complete process and
there I expect a major additional
benefit by a concept that essentially
provides the full integrated workflow
and then these integrated data analytics
pipeline based on the ingenuity
technology is so key for the proper
interpretation drawing the right
conclusions because it's not just
producing NGS data it's really doing the
data interpretation which is also
recognized as a major bottleneck in this
field at the moment I'm not aware of
another product like the question and
yes work so it's not just a chain with
its the overflow so therefore and we're
convinced that this is the best way to
go one application neck's it is my
pleasure thank you for thank you dr.
conquer that informative presentation
next it is my pleasure to introduce
Sabine assessor colleague Selene
ethically studied biology at Henry kine
University Dusseldorf Germany and
specialized in biomedicine he conducted
his master's thesis
a Peter McCollum Cancer Center in
Melbourne Australia analyzing gene
expression profiles in chronic lizards
lymphocytic leukemia in october 2007 he
joined the global product management
team at hydrogen in Hilden in germany
and has been responsible for managing
multiple automated platforms in
bioinformatics solutions mr. Scalli the
floor is yours
thank you very much
so I hope you can see the slide here and
thanks for this very nice introduction
and so I would like actually to now just
briefly reiterate how the gene Witter
NGS system actually enables to yeah be
up and running after only 30 days and
there's actually five design criterias
which I would like to explain here
before though I would like to share this
slide here so basically we started
actually with a question first and that
question was what is the what is the
ultimate objective of next-generation
sequencing and as you could see already
also within the slides that dr. Khan has
shown before the ultimate objective that
was identified after speaking to all of
these labs that are experts in
next-generation sequencing was this this
report here so to end up with an
actionable report at the end of the NGS
workflow so to take all of this data
that next-generation sequencing can
actually generate and only end up with a
one or two pager that shows the most
actionable information only and to reach
that objective actually there was five
design criterias identified the first
one is to be as complete as possible
actually dr. Kong has shown that already
but I would like to just read revisit
this point
very briefly the second one is to be as
actionable as possible the third one is
to be as flexible as possible with
multiple flow cells that can be
sequenced in parallel so that the lab
can scale up and down depending on how
many samples need to be processed and
then the fourth and the fifth go back to
the first one so because this solution
is supposed to be as complete as
possible also there was the design
criteria then to use this completeness
and make the pricing also as complete as
possible it's transparent as possible
but also as flexible as possible and
then the last one is service so to have
a holistic service along the entire
workflow as well so what does truly
complete mean you have seen that slide
already before so I don't want to spend
too much time on that so it means not
only that we cover the entire workflow
so extraction target enrichment library
prep sequencing data analysis and
interpretation but also the respective
automation and then very importantly it
was hard before quality control and then
user support you actually could see the
user support tool in the video before
the iPad app that really guides the user
through the entire workflow so that the
user wouldn't have to worry about user
documentation anymore and then last but
not least data management so this is
actually a very powerful tool that shows
on one single screen the entire workflow
in terms of how many samples do I have
in a laboratory that are currently in
extraction how many of these samples and
I actually also which samples have
passed the QC or maybe fail to Cocina
her to be reprocessed and this for the
entire workflow so how many samples at
library prep and sequencing and which of
these and what happened at the QC here
very powerful also then forelimbs
integration later on so actually it's
it's almost like a laboratory
information management system from
sample to insight that only leads the
limbs in and limbs out configuration and
ready is the Lim's integration so this
is the completeness of the entire
workflow and I just wanted to highlight
actually that every essay that has been
developed for
Jean Ritter NGS system undergoes this
entire workflow in terms of development
and harmonization to really achieve the
results that were shown before by dr.
Kong and especially to achieve or to
enable this report in the end and
especially to enable this in in 30 days
so this is the completeness and actually
just to summarize this very briefly so
the completeness really is addressing or
avoiding the pain of harmonizing the
entire upstream solutions it also avoids
the pain of you know maybe even having
to build a bioinformatics department
from scratch and really is about
realizing a true solution so not just
you know to have one or two parts of the
workflow covered but really a true
solution from sample to inside as we say
that has been fully harmonized before it
actually leaves our research and
development and our stock and towards
towards a lab the second design criteria
is it to be focused really focused only
in the most actionable insight and to do
this actually with and actually I'm
going to start with this slide here to
do this in a way that is not only lets
say holistic but also at the same time
is at the state of the art in terms of
medical and scientific knowledge we go
back actually to this cogent knowledge
base which has been built over almost
the last two decades so in there there
is over 13 million findings as you can
see here over 20,000 disease classes
over 30 different databases over 30,000
publications and over 340 thousand
samples that have been analyzed and this
database is then used of other ways also
this database is updated on a weekly
basis and this database is used to
design the panels in the first place to
make sure that really
most actionable insights are being
covered here to not drown in data later
on which is not actionable and therefore
get the most out of the system and they
talk about the technology and action
ability in this case has been geared
towards either a treatment option
clinical trials or professional
guidelines and for the first panel that
has been launched on the gene reader NGS
system the actionable insights tumor
panel that knowledge base has been used
to query that knowledgebase for the
solid tumors with the highest prevalence
the greatest need for testing which
means that these solid treatments have
the most variance actually which are
associated with actionable insights and
you can see in the left-hand bubble
actually be the results out of that
query were and the big five solid tumors
so no huge surprise here with melanoma
colorectal lung ovarian and breast and
12 genes that are covered with this
actionable insights tumor panel so it's
a very powerful first line testing for
solid tumor panels this slide here
actually shows the footprint of the
panel and some other parameters such as
the inside sizes the amplicons and click
on size and DNA input throughput and
variant frequency in amplicon coverage
and buried inside coverage and also
compares these comparators to let's say
similar solutions that are out there and
what can be seen here is certainly the
throughput is one parameter where the
action bin size tumor panel gives the
highest flexibility into in terms of
samples per run but then also the
amplicon coverage as you can see here is
very high and the very inside coverage
is also very high
we have also analyzed this sample
actually on excuse me this assay the
actionable insights tumor panel in terms
of actionable insights or actionable
there
which are actually being missed by
similar solutions out there so this is
just due to the fact of that knowledge
base that we are using for the design in
the very first place which is highly
geared towards actionable insights only
and matter of fact what you can see here
is on the bottom the total is the number
of variants actionable variants which
are missed by other solutions so you can
see here are hundreds and 80 are being
missed 117 and even if you would combine
these two essays together you would
still be missing around 18 actionable
variants so again this is just showing
the design criteria of actionability
that is behind this with the with the
knowledge base that knowledge base
allows later in the bioinformatics so
actually I should actually start with
the analysis first the analysis is very
straightforward it it has been actually
again as the entire workflow highly
optimized towards the application at
hand and there's this is basically a
push-button solution but at the same
time allows maximum visibility in terms
of if someone would actually would like
to review some of the variants manually
this is very nicely doable in the
analysis tool then the next tool which
we see on this slide here is the actual
interpretation tool and so what it what
it what it does is it doesn't only help
to directly create the report so the
degree of automation is is is is
definitely maximized but at the same
time we also have the maximum of
flexibility too so in other words what
you can see on this screen here is
before the report is being created one
can review the interpretation officing
of a variant at hand so you can see here
on the on top some further details with
respect to that variant and also below
whether it's pathogenic or not and then
below that you even see
the missins effect on the protein I hope
it's actually better readable on your
side that on my side here and then even
the treatment information can be
selected here and set in terms of the
evidence level as well so it is really a
combination of
high degree of automation to get that
report but at the same time it's very
flexible to if one would like to deep
dive into it and also very customizable
as well and very transparent to so all
of the information where where where
this interpretation is coming from which
publication this has been drawn from or
which clinical trial or which which
professional guideline all of that
information is in here as well so it's a
very powerful tool for the
interpretation to create that report so
that was the actionable inside tumor
panel what we are launching right now is
also a bracha panel which is targeting
both breast and ovarian and also both
mutation types germline or somatic and
is highly geared towards clinical
actionability of PARP inhibitors and the
next slide is actually just briefly
showing the design criterias for that
bracha essay so we are covering the
entire exons plus 20 base pairs flanking
on each side and the small in Dale's go
below six base pairs and then large in
delts reached 40 down to a sensitivity
of 5% the specificity above 90% and the
amplicon coverage here as you can see is
very high as well so this is the Chi Act
bracha panel and again as I said before
every essay is not just harmonized in
terms of that essay itself but really is
embedded into this entire workflow and
undergoes heavy development in
harmonization before before it's being
released and that includes again of
course of our informatics as well this
is just one screenshot showing the
interpreter
tool here again for Braco and here you
can see how it's being highlighted
either in red if it's pathogenic or
green if it's benign and then you can go
through that and actually do the same
settings as we have seen before so here
again the treatment information can be
set in terms of from the evidence level
and then one can go through the
different hits that this knowledge base
had in terms of in terms of publications
with respect to treatments or treatment
options or or clinical trials then I
would also like to briefly show you
another panel which we are currently
launching which is the Chi Act long
panel and as you may know very well lung
is an interesting use case here
especially because there's so many
different variants that need to be
detected and some of them are really
tricky - such as the point mutation here
at EGFR large deletions like the met
exon 14 or the Alex E and V or fusions
and and the left hand side here are
really just examples and by no means the
entire content of the long panel but
just examples of let's say tricky
mutation types that needs to be detected
in lung cancer and on the right hand
side you can see how many different
technologies usually are being utilized
to cover all of these different mutation
types and the technologies to reach from
PCR IHC up to fish and arrays and this
is especially an interesting case let's
say where next generation sequencing can
help to drive or to offer one single
essay that includes all of these results
and that's exactly the aim of the lung
of the kayak long panel as you can see
on this slide here so it's it's geared
towards 100% action ability you can see
here with around 550 mutations covering
all sort of all sorts of a mutation
types of whether it's snv's small or
large in the LC
these fusions and then the sensitivity
you can see here goes down to 5% for
FFPE or below 1% for liquid bar see the
specificity again is above 90% and then
the variant coverage is also very high
to reach all of these specifications
here one thing I would like to highlight
here especially with respect to the long
panel and all of the other essays that
are developed for the gene with NGS
system is the unique molecular indices
technology actually which uses again
unique molecular indices or um is to be
to tag original DNA molecules at the
very beginning of the library prep or
after extraction so to say to to be able
to identify those original molecules and
the idea behind that is very
straightforward you can see this here in
the two cases
um so once we detect a variant then
after library prep and after target
enrichment especially after PCR
amplification then this um I technology
can be used to to strengthen the the
statistical significance of a false
positive or a true positive on the left
hand side we see the case of a false
positive on the left hand bottom and
there you can see that there was the
star means the mutation and you can see
that that mutation seems to have
occurred only in one of the of the
original molecules and all of the other
copies of that original molecule
actually don't don't show that variance
so this is showing that very very
unlikely that this is a false positive
and it can be very nicely identified
then with strong signature on
statistical significance while on the
right hand side same or same case but in
this case it's actually a true positive
and of course by having those unique
molecular indices
one can say okay at each and every of
these original molecules actually had
this mutation of course this strengthens
this this detection of the true positive
by multiple magnitudes and actually the
the magnitude of that statistical
significance is shown on this slide here
so we asked our by limitations actually
to analyze and translate this into the Q
score and here you can see in this graph
the Q score before taking that you my
technology into account and you can see
a standard distribution around Q score
of 30 ish so a very normal standard
distribution here and then after the um
I technology has been taken into account
so after all of these stacks of of
molecules it can be traced down to the
same original molecule and the
significance of the statistical power
all that technology can now can then be
seen by this huge jump in the thread
score which actually had to be cut at 60
but just because yeah even 60 is
probably tough as a number to be lets
say experimentally verified and that's
why actually this cutoff had been taken
at 60 it's just showing actually what a
specific assay design can actually do if
it's combined with the right
bioinformatics analysis or the other way
around actually it's it's it's just
strengthening again this completeness
strategy to make sure that it's not just
about 1 or 2 component along the
workflow which needs to work nicely but
all of these components together if this
is orchestrated the right way you can
even leave the same sequencer in the
middle here as you can see with this
slide here just just by actually
controlling the assay design in a
specific way and the bioinformatics in a
specific way make sure that everything
is harmonized can have this huge jump
here
in terms of performance so it's just
another proof point actually for this
completeness factor which again is in
the end helping or geared towards that
report in the end and especially to to
enable that report within 30 days this
slide here actually stole so to say from
our R&D department so it's just showing
actually the development practice um and
when something is actually being
released so I thought I just show this
here because it just shows the due
diligence that goes into these assay
developments and again so maybe I'll
just briefly just explain so you can see
here experiments instruments users sites
and then different categories of let's
say statistical significance again and
every of course I mean of course there's
there's tons and tons of experiments
behind that but what I would like to
highlight here is that each experiment
or each of these levels here again
always means sample to inside so that
really the entire workflow has been
tested through tons of experiments
sample to inside same for the
instrumentation so multiple different or
talking to you definitely a lot of lots
of different instrumental setups that
that are being tested sample to inside
again also for the user sample to inside
and fights as well sample to insights
and only when all of these things come
together and and have been reproduced
multiple times along this entire
workflow and and I should actually again
note here sample two inside here does
not only mean the automation but
including the QC including that user
support to an including gene read link
as well the laboratory information
management system setup so only when all
of these things come together and then
the subsystems are being or subsystem
these results are being reviewed on the
subsystem level and then being reviewed
again on the system level only then
these these
says or these products actually are
being released so just to summarize this
very briefly so these the the design
towards actionability help really to
focus only on the most actionable
insights and enables actually to cover
hundreds of actionable insights which
other solutions are missing and
therefore also allow them this custom
report in the end and all of this
together with highest amplicon coverage
and batching flexibility so this was the
second point and I can actually see
already Q&A is coming in which I highly
welcome so we all look forward to the
Q&A session which is only a few slides
away by the way so the third point the
flexibility is actually something that
is rather straightforward I don't know
whether this slide will translate
because it's animated but so basically
the the main feature here is that the
gene reader NGS system or the gene
reader sequencer itself has this
turntable at its at its core and that
turntable actually allows true
parallelization of multiple flow cells
so in other words we can sequence up to
three flow cells or anything in between
and whether one flow cell or three flow
cells are being sequenced does not make
a difference to the actual sequencing
turnaround time because while the one
flow cell is actually being sequenced
the other ones are undergoing liquid
liquid handling so to say incubation and
then as soon as one flow cell has been
actually sequence the next flow cell is
being lifted towards the camera to
undergo sequencing as well and this just
allows there's there's the summary slide
missing so this just allows the
sequencer to scale up and down just
depending on how many samples come in
one can then choose whether it's the one
flow or the two flows away and therefore
the sequencer the gene or NGS system
scales up and down to
with the number of samples that need to
be processed point number four is going
back to the completeness of the entire
workflow so because the entire workflow
really takes everything into account
including QC etc we can give full cost
transparency here too which sounds
trivial but very often if a workflow is
fragmented there's a multiple SKUs I
mean double-digit of screws involved and
just accounting wise this is actually
becoming a challenge and here we can
give full cost transparency which was a
very important design criteria actually
and then also have three different
pricing models the one is the the capex
perching or purchasing option then there
is a reagent rental and then there is
also a paper insight which actually
allows us even to share some of the
operational some of the operational
risks that NGS still cover the still
includes so then this is basically
mainly the number of samples that are
being put on a flow cell if the number
of samples is going up or down this will
directly affect the price per sample and
we can use this price per inside
actually to regulate that and to share
some of that risk with the lab okay and
so with this I'm actually at the last
point which is the holistic service and
this again goes back actually to the
completeness of the workflow so because
so again it's out that sounds trivial
but that was very important also for NGS
labs when we were interviewing them that
you know doing troubleshooting or
whatever that it's actually one contact
that can be used here to to troubleshoot
but also to initialize an operational as
an entire laboratory and there's many
cutting edge solutions here from
application training to consulting
remote diagnostic that we can offer here
with the gene
system and with this I would like to
actually just end with this slide here
which is just showing so again just to
summarize so the design criteria where
to be truly complete as actionable as
possible as flexible as possible with
the multiple flow cells to offer
guaranteed results with predictable cost
and have this one service contact and
actually now with with the new panels
that we are launching now and the
detection of scene B's infusions and the
molecular the unique molecular indices
were strengthening this actionability
very significantly and then also
increase the financial attractiveness
which is point number five for and by
also twisting the system or increasing
some system efficiency we were enabling
to increase the number of samples that
can be put on a flow cell and therefore
actually allow the entire system to be
more efficient and all of these things
again are geared towards this one
objective or to enable this one
objective which is the actionable report
in the end and enable this especially
within 30 days from installation so with
this I am at the end of my slides and I
would actually just briefly check
whether we have the time to just show
very briefly the video from dr. akari's
laboratory and her user experience and
then open it up for the Q&A which I can
see already coming in here cancer is a
genetic disease it messes up the DNA
sequence and we need to know everything
that goes on we want to be able to offer
that kind of testing being able to look
at several genes at the same time and
next-generation sequencing is the only
technology available to do that and yes
is a very complex technology and it has
several elements from the DNA extraction
all the way to the library preparation
to the sequencing and then the
bioinformatics all the way to reporting
I think there's a huge need for a one
workflow process in NGS the NGS system
that kaijin offers is end-to-end
solution in one workflow it really has
no competition out there honestly um it
empowered us which we loved right we
love the idea that we can do something
very complex in a very simple manner
simple cheaper higher quality manner and
that's very attractive you get out of
the messiness of piecing together a
process and get into just one process
its cohesive and it is easy to
troubleshoot which in a lab operation it
is P in order to keep our operation
flowing properly tangent really is a
collaborator at this point they can help
us they can help us do better and that's
what you know ultimately with ri4 thank
you mr. Asif Ali for your informative
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how does no question simply
type them in the Q&A lock sound by
clicking on the green Q&A button has a
lower left of the presentation window we
will get to as many questions as time
permits
so our further ado let's hop in and ask
the first question
the first question asks how do the
multiple cell configurations work yep
so um Yi or do you want to take this or
Anton briefly drinking yeah the way
those small cells work as Salim showed
earlier there are three flow cells in 1d
or system that can each be run
individually
simultaneously or in a staggered fashion
and as Salim explained this offers the
greatest level of flexibility for
laboratories especially those with some
fluctuation in their sample so you can
choose to run one or two or three today
and then tomorrow if you only run one or
two you could run the other two or one
slow cells in the staggered fashion
hi everyone today in question the next
question asks where can I find more
information on the system can I see a
demo the answer is absolutely you can
find more information on gene reader and
GS comm and you can absolutely see a
demo as well there is a contact us
button on the website and you could also
feel free to reach out to anyone of us
here and you can also we will also be
attending a number of upcoming
conferences such a us cap ACMG and
amberlynn as I was referring to earlier
and you'll be able to see the generator
up and close and get a personal demo
there that's one thank you for your
answer
our next question asks will will there
be gene reader report template be
provided to reflect the recent
guidelines standards and guidelines for
interpretation and reporting of sequence
variants in cancer if I understood
correctly I think the question is asking
whether the guideline information will
be updated and that will be reflected in
the report and the answer to that
question is absolutely so the database
is actually continuously mined and added
to and modified to on an ongoing basis
occasion we have a team of content
curators whose sole job is to do just
that so any information new information
vaccine whether that's a modification of
a guideline information or it's a
addition or deactivation of a clinical
trial that will be captured in just
about real-time and reflected in our
knowledge database
so when a tumor sample when a report is
run through the database the information
you get in that report will reflect the
most current information that's been
updated in the database in your
laboratory because the interpretation
piece will be web-based you will have
automatically real-time connection to
the latest and greatest in our database
okay thank you for that answer our next
question is asked how do you determine
the appropriate way to interpret report
cytogenetic changes that are
traditionally determined by FISH is this
problematic for companion diagnostic
Salim you don't take that one sure so
the fish or yes is especially based on
fusion detection and fusion detection we
enabled through an RNA sequencing
application actually and in a way
actually that does not does not have to
sequence the entire RNA how would you
say the entire expression of the RNA
molecule but is especially tagged
towards towards towards the beginning
which already shows whether whether
there has been for example it's skipping
event or or not so so and and with
respect to the actual what that means
for CD CDX well I mean the easiest way
to answer that is probably to deep dive
into this technology a little further
and show you how this is actually being
accomplished and then check what the
requirements would be and then just take
it from there
thank you so much for your answer we
have another question coming in today
and it asked effort they asked this
looks like a very interesting platform
does this enable harmonization
of results from Bobbitt's
pharmacogenomic test si Yi did one or I
can give it a brief shot so um I thinks
thanks for ya confirming the the
platform design let's say and
harmonization of results is exactly what
what we want to achieve here is I'm glad
to hear that with respect to
pharmacogenomics we have been looking
into this there is no standard there is
no assay actually that we have developed
so far but depending on again what the
requirements here would be it's always
interesting to hear this back you know
from from the expert labs and we of
course are always looking for fruitful
companions here to develop something
together or at least gather gather the
requirements from from the expert labs
so again here if you would like to
discuss this further this would probably
be the best way to find out if and how
we could realize such such an
application anything anything to add yep
no I think that's it so you know
obviously at the moment we do not have
an application that automatically
combines your enables the
pharmacogenomic test but that's not to
say that you know that's something that
we should explore and we definitely
welcome we chop them from people who
might be interested in this I
thank you so much for your answers looks
like we're running a little close on
time so we'll ask one more question
today how many samples can you process
yeah so one can process depending on the
panel for the pan tumor panel let's
color the hotspot panel one can process
16 up to 16 samples per flow cell times
3 so up to 48 samples at the same time
but again you know with the flexibility
you don't have to run all 48 at the same
time and you can choose to run just in
in you know one follows one flow cell at
a time so up to 16 one you know minimum
you can run one of course but a maximum
48 with a lot of flexibility in between
thank you for your answer I would like
to once again thank dr. Kong and mr.
Rasik Ali for your presentations
dr. Kong do you have any final comments
you'd like to leave it up today I just
want to say that you know thank you
again for all of your time and attention
we know a G reader is a new system and
we definitely would would welcome any
further interest in Fernie any further
questions and I know we didn't get time
to go through all of your questions so I
welcome you all to reach out afterwards
thank you
excellent thank you and mr. ethically do
you have any final comments you'd like
to leave us no just also we'd like to
extend the thanks and I really like the
the type of questions that came in so it
really shows yum it's a pity that we
can't go through all of them so if you'd
like to contact us later on we're very
happy to continue the discussion thank
you so much I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and thank
lab roots for today's educational
webcast and cryogen for sponsoring the
webcast this path
can be viewed on-demand through May 2017
Roberts roller easy email when it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that you know with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
this is Christina with Roberts and we
look forward to seeing you here next
time at Larry's calm goodbye